is 64 gigabytes a complete waste of
money for the new m1 max macbook pros or
is it noticeably faster than the 32
gigabyte version well today we will find
out because we are gonna do a
multitasking ram stress test including
much longer tougher projects for video
editing for a blender even windows 11
with virtual machines and we will find
out once and for all if it's worth
spending that extra money or if you
should spend it on ssds or other
upgrades now in front of me you see a 16
inch and a 14 inch macbook pro they both
have 10 core processors they both have
32 graphic scores but the difference is
32 gigs for the 16 inch 64 for the base
now yesterday i compared both of these
and i found out where they perform
exactly the same and where we do have
some differences and i have all those
previous results now ideally i'd prefer
to have both identical sizes but because
apple won't send that to us they delayed
it for another two weeks or so we're
doing it this way and we're gonna see
the performance differences from
baseline without ram being filled two
once our ram is filled up to see if the
64 core will maintain its performance
and the 32 might slow down or both of
them will slow down or both will
maintain them that will be the
interesting part as you guys see the
cpus they literally are matching up
identically in cinebench when we ran it
it literally was identical as well and
graphics performance for certain
workloads were also very similar and
let's go ahead and jump into this let's
start by loading up the ram i have 10
tabs open here in safari and then i'm
opening 20 more tabs in chrome with a
wide variety of different things such as
auto playing ads in the background that
keep reloading different news websites i
have tons of images a really good
youtube video with autoplay in the
background my google drive that has a
ton of stuff pre-loaded i scrolled all
the way down
tons of stuff here i have a document i
have a spreadsheet open here and a bunch
of other tabs including autoplay video
that runs in background of a different
one too i have adobe creative cloud
opening it looks like it's updating
something right now so we have a real
rule test with a bunch of stuff open and
right of the gate looks like we have
over 18 gigs used on the 16 model and
about 21 on the 32 now we do have a tiny
bit of swap right here 23 megabytes i
don't know why that's there because we
have 32 gigs so bam we have that done
and the next i'm going to do is open up
adobe photoshop and open up 10 42
megapixel raw images all 10 of them are
loaded up into the ram and of course
we're not seeing any performance
differences because if we're not maxing
out the ram you won't see a difference
between these two that's why i'm loading
all of these up and right now if we take
a look at our activity monitor we
already have 30 gigs filled on the 64
gig model and 27 and a half on the 32
now let's go ahead and minimize this
we're going to open up adobe lightroom
which definitely suffers in performance
if you don't have enough ram it's
probably the most ram dependent program
i've used and right here i have 50 raw
images that are color graded so each
time i'm switching has to load up the
image and apply all of the effects of
course we do have the same 10 core
processor here
so um it's using that to apply it's also
using graphics performance about 50
graphics if you guys see that right
there so both are being used and the
performance is basically the same so far
and wow look at that look at that memory
pressure now on the 32 gig model um we
are using only 25 gigs out of 32 whereas
on the 64 gig we're at 40 gigs already
so here the swap hasn't went up at all
but it's caching more it's trying to
limit the ram usage which has me
wondering are we going to get better
performance now with all those tabs open
and photoshop with 10 images
if we go ahead and export this project
let's go ahead and see and bam we are
exporting and you can see that the
memory pressure is going even higher now
on the 32 gig model but nothing on the
64. it doesn't care it's not being
limited or even pressured at all and we
are done and i'm surprised to see that
the difference is only three seconds
it's sometimes within margin of error
there so we have a minute and 23 for the
32 gig model a minute 20 for the 64 gig
model and that is extremely extremely
fast for both of these now we're gonna
do this test one more time once we load
up more things into the memory to see if
it will slow down because we see that
pressure right there but for now let's
go ahead and minimize lightroom and we
will just keep that open in the
background next we're gonna run xcode
and this is one program where we did see
a difference between 16 and 32 gigs of
ram when we put a bunch of stuff in the
background running so let's go ahead and
run our benchmark looks like our 32 gig
mac is finally riding to the swap we're
at 4.33 gigs it's clearing out the
physical memory
where our 64 gig still isn't at all we
have a tiny spike of pressure almost
nothing and we're using 41 gigs right
now and look at that guys we have a
difference of about one and a half
seconds we have 99.1 compared to 100.7
i was expecting a bigger difference than
that because in our last test it was
like a 19 difference with the ram maxed
out and going into swap
but it looks like 32 gigs is a great
point where 16 just was not if you're
maxing it out and running xcode so very
interesting now to punish these machines
more let's go ahead and open up blender
we'll do some 3d rendering and i'm going
to start out with the party tug file
which you can download off blender's
website now this one uses a lot of the
graphics so right now with the ram being
maxed out on a 32 gig model is it gonna
have to pull some of that in order to
give gpu resources let's go ahead and
find out and then after this one i'm
gonna do one that's very memory
intensive as well and look at that we
have six and a half seconds compared to
seven on our first run we should try it
again to make sure it's consistent let's
run it and bam we have 6.33 compared to
6.5
ever so slightly slower just tiny bit
slower on the 16-inch and now i'm
opening up our memory test and this
thing uses i think 20 times the memory
of the previous project i scaled all the
counts over here and the viewport and
with this memory test even without
anything pre-loaded i saw a difference
of about a second from 16 and a half
seconds up to 17 and a half seconds just
with the difference between 32 gigs of
ram and 64. but now with our ram loaded
up as you guys could see we're using 26
gigs here 45 here but here we're also
dipping into the swap as well almost
four and a half gigs of swap with all
that pressure let's see what kind of
difference that makes all right there
you guys go
we have
20.88 seconds compared to 28 seconds on
the 32 gig model
that literally i think is like a 20 gig
uh render that has to go through the ram
there massive massive file i mean this
is torture test status that's 33 faster
for the 64 gig model now of course most
people aren't going to be doing anything
that takes up that amount of memory but
if you're doing video production and
you're doing photorealistic cgi that has
to go into that that is where these kind
of projects get so heavy so if you're
doing this and you have lightroom and
photoshop open and 30 tabs with stuff
definitely 64 is showing us a difference
now before i push these machines further
i want to mention that with all of that
done we have over nine gigs of memory
written to the swap on the 32 gig model
whereas the 64 still has
zero now with that said the ssds are
much faster on these new macbooks than
the ones before which will help so right
now before we test more we're gonna see
what has to be loaded if there's any
slowdowns and the memory bandwidth with
these machines are up to 400 gigabytes
per second compared to about
gigabytes per second with the previous
i9 16 inch macbook that is just a huge
difference so let's go ahead and jump
back into safari and we're going to see
are these tabs still here and if there
have to be reloaded how long is that
going to take and it looks like
bam no delays at all with safari nothing
is getting reloaded nothing is slowing
down on the 32 gig model because it's
reading from swap that is amazing and
now let's go to chrome let's jump to
this auto play video it is still running
perfectly on both
no slow downs whatsoever on eight
gigabyte m1 max right now you would
definitely be getting a lot of reloading
and here as you guys see we are not
let's open up this google doc
bam how about google drive probably the
hardest one
i don't know
literally it looks the same on both 64
and 32 gig models
i'm not getting refreshing how about our
youtube video hey it's maxtec autoplayed
that is awesome it's working so
literally we are having no issues yet
just a little bit faster in xcode so
with that said let's close this down and
i'm going to open a crazy video project
if you guys check this out right here
this project is nearly 600 gigabytes and
no that's not in prores that's like
compressed h.264 footage that's how long
these videos take and how much space
they take up let's click open on both of
them at the same time
wow guys that literally was the same i'm
at different points in the video but no
differences there and this project right
here
slows down so much on our m1 imac with
16 gigs after we have all these titles
different animations color grading
pop-ups music everything loaded up in a
project that's over a half hour long
with multi-cam 4k and as soon as we hit
the slide out it stutters and starts
going crazy but it looks like both of
these are having no issues at all now
one thing we get is a little bit of slow
down when we're trying to spread these
nodes and it looks like even on the 64
gig model with this huge project we're
still seeing that kind of stuttering
which is unfortunate maybe it's just the
plug-in instead of the actual software
or the ram limitations and now let's go
ahead and export this 30 minute and 46
second
4k project and right away we're getting
some more pressure on both of these
systems but nothing like i expected with
it all the way being up with all of this
still in the background just to remind
you guys we have lightroom open with
those 50 edited images we have 10 raws
in photoshop we still have terminal
running over here we have the 30
different tabs in chrome and in safari
open and even with all of that these are
still neck and neck exporting this crazy
video that just slows down our m1i mac
to a halt
of course that has a hundred gigabyte
per second memory bandwidth and 60 gigs
these are 400 over here and 32 and 64
gig with double the speed of the ssds so
it seems like it just doesn't care
alright guys and wow so
with all of the background stuff open
lightroom photoshop
everything else with 30 tabs and all the
stuff that i wouldn't leave open that
long this 30 minute 46 second project
just exported in 8 minutes and 52
seconds on both systems no difference
whatsoever
wow people said hey if you go longer on
these projects it's gonna start coming
in you know what guys look at that
project right there this is what we
struggle with on our m1s when we start
getting these 30 minutes 38 minute
projects
no issues whatsoever so what i'm gonna
do is i'm gonna go ahead and minimize
i'm gonna keep that huge project open in
the memory and what i'm gonna do next is
launch windows 11 so we're running a
virtual machine of windows 11 through
parallels now our 32 gig model can only
use 26 gigs of that for windows whereas
we can use i think 52 or 56 from the 64
gig model now i pre-tested these systems
and this is what i got as far as
geekbench 5 performance through virtual
machines
this is actually using six cores out of
the 10 and i am using the pro version if
you want to get the best performance and
full access to the most amount of ram
you need the pro version but you guys
can save 10 off using our code that will
link down in the video description and
now what i want to do is with all of
that ram in mac os and now we have
windows on top of that we have the 30
minute project we have lightroom
photoshop i want to go ahead and open up
geekbench 5 and test that again all
right we have our scores
and they are practically the same
just ever so slightly higher on the 64
gig model they both just went slightly
lower than we had before everything was
loaded up just parallels uh and then i
also went ahead and i ran speedometer
2.0
both of them did slow down uh compared
to just having parallels with windows 11
open and nothing else but they are both
very close just ever so slightly slower
than a 232 gig
way faster than the intel macbooks
running mac os so that is still really
surprising so what i'm going to do now
is switch back to mac os let's take a
look here we have 56 gigs filled on the
64 gig no swap and then 28 now on the 32
gig model with 7.6 gig swap less than b4
which is surprising
wow windows 11 is using a lot of memory
what the heck i don't know if that's
accurate 44 gigs for windows 11 on the
32 gig and 90 on the 64.
i don't know if that's accurate at all
but we're gonna keep windows 11 through
parallels virtual machine opened up in
the background and let's go through our
different applications bam we have
photoshop open no slowdowns on the 32gb
model let's go through these photos each
one of these raw images they're very
large
and they are not slowing down at all
there's literally no differences
flipping between them super responsive
even on the 32 gig one that's in swap
back in the intel days that would have
been horrific trying to open that it'd
be so slow it'd be crashing so now let's
just go ahead and try to open up
lightroom
bam let's flip through some of these
photos
i am not seeing any differences
it's super super responsive
more responsive than a macbook just a
couple years ago by itself trying to
load these up a lot more responsive
let's try to go ahead and zoom into this
image
man no issues unless you use brushes ah
super smooth on both of them that is
crazy i don't know what else to do how
about we open up logic on both of these
systems
just to use up some more ram i have our
benchmark project open here with 128
tracks being played
looks like both of them are still
handling it without an issue let's turn
on the speakers
okay
we still have those autoplay videos in
the background running
all right crazy
let's go ahead and bounce this project
i'll just go ahead and export it to say
uh let's do an mp3 we'll set that to the
highest bit rate for mp3 and let's
bounce now if you want to know more info
about this project the effects and
everything else just search up new logic
benchmark online the info is there and
so far they look like they're running
exactly the same our cpus are maxed out
we are using some graphics as well
stuff is getting hot
uh but wow okay bam took 42 seconds to
do that identical on both systems i'm
gonna go ahead and minimize logic but
we're gonna keep it open because we're
gonna load up the ram still and look at
that we're only using 2.6 gigs of swap
on the 32 gig model and here we're still
at zero we have more memory pressure
here but it's just above halfway that's
crazy how are we using 55 gigs of ram
here but only 28 and a half
plus a little bit of swap over here and
both systems are equally running
um that's just insane you know what
let's go ahead and export this test
again
this is where it really starts slowing
down more before when we tested in the
past but of course we've never tested
apple silicon with up to 64 gigs and 32
as well man the 16 gig macbook handled
multitasking extremely well
but i can't believe how good the 32 gig
is doing in this case
if you're gonna be hitting it with
everything you've got we still have
windows 11 open
through virtual machines we still have
lightroom in photoshop and logic and
final cut with a 30 minute timeline we
still have all these google renderers
for all the ads in the background of the
30 tabs open
and this thing is just still flying with
only 32 gigs of ram all right bam the 64
gig just beat out the 32 gig it took a
minute and 24 seconds compared to a
minute and 33
so that was a nine second difference
within lightroom this is where we saw
the most difference previously in
multitasking ram stress tests when we
were comparing the m1 and intel systems
this is what would be a huge difference
so what else can i do to the system i
guess we can open up an 8k raw project
that absolutely destroys the system this
is one where the 14 inch was not as fast
as a 16 inch with the m1 max processor
because our cpus max out our gpu is
maxed out but i have the results for
both systems so let's see if the 16 inch
is still faster
or if the 64 gigs will help it and we'll
see how much each one slows down so i'm
going to keep this project right here
open the 30 minute project and let's
open up this ak one as well so as you
see we have both this project open bam
this one and bam let's go ahead and
export it i know that's a lot of bams
but i don't know what else to throw at
the system
so far they're running at the same speed
oh nope the 16 inch is going fast the 32
gig model is starting the inch ahead
just a little bit
showing that the 64 isn't helping it
that much yet it just has more power for
the graphics so very interesting now
while this is happening let's see how
responsive our system is while we have
all this loaded up let's go ahead and
open up parallels i'm going to open up
our windows virtual machine
wow instant on both while exporting ak
raw video maxing out the cpu and the gpu
let's switch tabs here
bam
let's go to the first test we had
let's go ahead and minimize this
bam let's slide back into
a mac os right there
let's go ahead and open up
lightroom classic
bam
let's switch between photos here
oh my goodness
okay i saw one that loaded slightly
slower but other than that
gosh this is crazy let's open up
photoshop right there switch to this
first photo
oh right there you guys see that we have
a difference
right there it took longer to open up
the first raw uh probably because it was
in the swap and we're exporting aka this
is actually the hardest test i found for
these systems because the cpu and gpu
are maxed out our ram is maxed out
everything's maxed out let's switch okay
that time it already knew i'm trying to
use photoshop
wow okay so did it really pull all that
from swap and put it back into the ram
just to have it be much faster let's see
what's happening in the activity monitor
so even with all that we're still not
using any swap on the 64 gig and now
we're up to
11.18 gigs of swap on the 32 and the
pressure is moving higher
so keep in mind we still have logic open
still photoshop lightroom we still have
that 30 minute project right there open
should we go ahead and play this while
we're exporting let's try that i think
it might mess up some of the tests but
so far we have 30 percent
36 right here basically the same
difference that we had before
let's do this i think it's going to
pause our export for a second longer
okay that is responsive i'll let it do
its thing again that's crazy and all
right guys the exports are done
and
both of them were slightly slower than
before by about a minute
um and i was also messing around and
opening up photoshop and going through
those photos while it was exporting the
ak which is the toughest test that i
found for these machines and i opened up
windows as well through the virtual
machine while i was exporting so and the
ram is full so it makes sense why they
both slowed down even though we didn't
have any swap here we had swap here but
both equally slowed down by about a
minute compared to not having logic open
or photoshop or lightroom or windows or
30 tabs or any of that stuff i'm just
shocked by how well
these macs run even with 32 gigabytes
just to show you guys again bam i have
both of those projects open this is the
30 minute one
and now let's just go back into
photoshop and i want to see if this is
still less responsive because we're not
rendering anymore before we're maxing
out the cpu and the gpu and the ram
and we're also pulling from swap
look at that
now that i'm not exporting the 8k raw
literally no difference and our ram is
still
maxed out now let's jump back into
safari we haven't done this for a bit
let's see if any of that has to be
reloaded remember we have virtual
machines open we just did that render
gosh
this is unbelievable
my mac pro
cannot do this and i have a crazy amount
of ram when you're doing this kind of
stuff it just slows down uh let's go
ahead and open up google chrome we
haven't opened that up for a bit either
wow okay
let's jump through
bam
bam
bam
bam how is this possible
how is this possible
look at that
they're playing the same video at the
same spot all right google drive okay
this thing has to get reloaded on the 32
gig if it doesn't
okay why did i say that look at oh i'm
used to this literally it would just
reload it would reload if you're doing a
half of this or a quarter of this on my
previous 16 inch macbook um yeah a
quarter of not even a quarter of this uh
it would do that but
that's just crazy
let's play that first one with the
autoplay video look at that alright guys
so where did we see a noticeable
difference
um oh my goodness it just keeps going we
still have logic over here too let's see
all right
yeah logic is still here
we're still playing
so
what's the deal here with 32 gigs well i
pushed this way harder than in the video
between 16 and 32. in that video i said
16 performs shockingly well you guys
said it's not enough you guys said we
gotta run more samples we gotta do crazy
tests uh we let's let's find this crazy
extreme memory benchmark for uh blender
where you're pulling 20 gigs in a quick
render rushing through the memory there
in that case yeah it was faster 33
faster which could be significant 20
seconds compared to 28 seconds uh but
that was with everything else pre-loaded
in the background i don't know if you're
if you know you're doing some insane
memory intensive renders you'd probably
want to close that i don't know
and then
the ak test i thought the 32 gig would
surely fail or that 30 minute long 4k
real world project with all the graphs
and bars multi-cam all that stuff
overall
what i see is 32 gigs is insanely good
i was also expecting lightroom to go
much slower when you would have all that
opened up and the windows 11 virtual
machines you guys like i said open that
up too that's what really slows it down
i'm not seeing it the 32 gig is
performing shockingly well
so
if you are hesitating this is the final
verdict if you are hesitating at all
about needing 64 gigs you don't need 64
gigs this 32 gig performs better than an
intel macbook with 64 gigs um
the intel i9 spec'd out 16-inch macbook
pro would just be stuttering at this
point the unified memory going up to 400
gigabytes a second compared to like 42
before with that 64 gig i9 macbook just
a year ago
massive difference and the ssds being
twice as fast makes a massive difference
as well this thing is just crazy
responsive now if you know that you're
working for hollywood and you're doing
motion vf or you're doing vfx for movies
and it has to look photorealistic
yeah if you know that you're going to
run renders with 20 gig uh render files
that are going through the memory
you you know you need it then you need
it but if you're hesitating at all
and you care about money
then you don't need it stick with 32
gigs i have the 32 gig one myself and i
was wondering man am i gonna have to
just get the 64 gig
i threw everything i could at it and
more oh i took your guy's suggestions
and you guys see the results right here
now if you don't care about money
i mean why do you could just buy
anything you could buy a bentley buy
whatever
if you could do that you can uh but even
if you don't care about money look at
how this is performing 32 gigs
you don't need 64 gigs so there you guys
go that is my final verdict unless you
know that what you're doing
takes an insane amount of memory
like that blender render with this which
which has insane samples and everything
there just push to the max which most
people don't know don't do or if you're
doing logic
and you're running insane amounts of
plugins that you know your intel macbook
with 64 gigs just crashed
okay get 64 gigs here um or
i don't even know what else if you're
running 10 20 virtual machines
and you know that even the macbook
before could never handle you had to
have a mac pro
with a crazy amount of ram now yeah you
can go with 64 gigs but for 99.9 of us
32 gigs is performing insanely well
embarrassing my 15 000 mac pro so there
you guys go click that circle above if
you guys want to see our final full
reviews on these m1 pro and m1 max
macbooks check out one of those great
videos right over there check out our
merch below we would greatly appreciate
it this has been max and i'll see you in
the next video
[Music]